Alright, why don't we walk through our solution
function compare_averages. Remember that we're performing a t-test on
two sets of baseball data, left-handed and right-handed
hitters. We want to perform a Welch's t-test and determine
with 95% confidence whether or not the average
batting average of the two cohorts is different. In
other words the left handed hitters have a statistically
significant different average batting average than right handed hitters.
First, we read our data into a panda's data
frame. So baseball date equals pandas.read_csv and then the
location of our csv file. Then we're going to
split the data into two data frames, one for left
handed hitters and one for right handed hitters. We
do this by saying baseball_data_left equals baseball_data, and then
index on baseball_data handedness equals L. We can do
the same thing for right-handed hitters. Then we'll use scipy.stats.ttest_ind
to perform a Welches t-test on these two data
frames. So results equals scipi.stats.ttest_ind and then we pass in
baseball data left average, baseball data right average, and
we say equal_var equals false. Now we're going to produce
an output in the desired format. So if result
one is less than or equal to .05, that is
if our p value is less than or equal to
.05, will return false and then the output of scipy.stats.ttest_ind.
Else will return true, and then the result of scipy.stats.ttest_ind. So this
is a basic implementation of how we can do Welch's t-test using Python.